messieurs bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
de débattre ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france alors le 3 juin dernier
emmanuel macron a remis le dossier des
retraites sur la table évoquant des
décisions difficiles le conseil
d'orientation des retraites nous apprend
que le trou est de 18 milliards d'euros
et que l' équilibre ne sera pas atteint
avant 2030 alors réformer les retraites
est ce que cela devient la priorité
aujourd'hui j'en pleurais coût des mots
d'abord faudra tous suffisait moi je ne
suis pas surpris en fin de compte des
propos du président cette issue est en
fin de compte de ceux qui de bruno le
maire devait rang sur cette stratégie
politique et budgétaire
donc on est on n'est pas surpris parce
que effectivement des temps devant une
tête qui devient un problème de
soutenabilité au niveau financier et il
faut trouver des solutions
évidemment c'est soit des nouvelles
recettes d'oise est exceptionnel par par
la pole impôts pour les plus riches mais
ça le gouvernement s'y refuse
complètement donc il s'engage il veut
s'engager en teckant vers des réformes
structurelles et donc ses priorités pour
vous de la de réformer les retraites
aujourd'hui
non moi je pense que justement c'est pas
une priorité on est encore en pleine
crise économique sociale même sanitaire
forcément complètement fini enfin
j'espère que contraint et grands tous
les corps mais nous voilà il y en a
besoin de stabilité en fin de compte
budgétaire il faut laisser je pense un
peu de temps le vu les déficits est
annoncée pour 2020 et je crois 25
milliards en fait compte soit 13
milliards on voit bien que en fin de
compte le le l'habitude budgétaire
indépendant allèles l'équilibré retraite
dépend aussi enfin quand de ses
équilibres budgétaires et des
l'évolution du pib
donc voilà il faut de la stabilité il ya
aussi des questions mesure peut-être
aujourd'hui complètement l'impact de la
survente est surmortalité qui a pu avoir
avec ses clefs sanitaire je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya bien 2 irrité que
leur exemple bertail j'ai laissé à leur
a donné la parole à jacques myard mer
les républicains de maisons laffitte s
qui a d'autres priorités aujourd'hui
selon
que vous rejoignez les propos de jean
louis bricout ou au contraire bien vous
vous dites il faut réformer ça devient
une priorité aux normands le
gouvernement ne fera pas cette réforme
actuellement pour des raisons politiques
stratégiques des élections
présidentielles car c'est un problème
extrêmement explosif au regard des
nécessités d'équilibré alors que ce soit
très clair je suis pour la retraite par
répartition
il ne faut pas abandonner ce système la
réforme des retraites par points est une
escroquerie
je le précise c'est ruraux script parce
qu'en vérité on voit très bien que ça va
être une réponse nouvelle forme à la
soviétique administrative on met tout le
monde dans le même sac et ensuite on
tient le niveau des retraites par la
valeur du point
troisièmement la loi d'airain en matière
de retraite
c'est le nombre d'actifs par rapport au
nombre des retraités et il faut
travailler sur ce set en jeu c'est la
réduction du chômage parce qu'il y aura
plus de effectivement de cotisation et
ça c'est l'investissement et la relance
et c'est aussi la politique nataliste et
je dirai à mon ex-collègue bricout que
malheureusement le gouvernement hollande
a foutu en l'air
la politique nataliste c'est que ça se
voit aujourd'hui parce qu'il manque 70
mille naissances et à terme c'est la
seule solution c'est à dire que les
générations doivent se renouveler
donc on a toute une série de paramètres
sur laquelle on peut le juger il faut
c'est une politique à long terme
il y as sans doute des recettes
supplémentaires à avoir par un certain
nombre de grands groupes qui ne cotisent
pas et qui échappent à la cotisation des
retraites
donc il faut de la justice sociale et de
la justice fiscale dans ce domaine et
donc que ce que nos doigts mais ça ne
sent maintenant parce que ça risque
d'être vraiment dangereux pour le
gouvernement
jean louis bricout peut-être que vous
pouvez répondre à jacques myard sur la
question de la politique familiale une
politique famille
pour jacques myard qui doit être pensée
1 pour l'avenir avec le déficit
démocratique démographique qui avait
d'ailleurs été soulignée par françois
bayrou en mai dernier qu'est ce que vous
répondez jean louis bricout
écoutez je pense pas qu'on ait porté
atteinte si brutalement que ça la
politique nataliste en france on avait
tout simplement pour ceux qui avaient
des des prestations familiales et
sociales soit moins élevé que pour ceux
qui ont moins de moyens
je trouve que y'a rien de choquant par
rapport à ça il faut inciter les
français à avoir plus d'enfants
aujourd'hui pour pour protéger notre
système
un bal lui il faut certes elle est
peut-être des mesures incitatives au
niveau 2 au niveau de la famille ça fait
partie des équilibres il n'y a pas un
gars pas que ça et on n'est pas si
mauvais que ça en france en terme de
politique familiale quoi donc je pense
pas que c'est la priorité absolue du
rapport à l'enjeu des retraites quale
l'enjeu il va se faire surtout sur les
équilibres entre les les dépenses et les
recettes
et tout ça ça dépend évidemment de
évidemment de la relance il parle de
croissance passée la part de croissance
qui amènera des nouvelles recettes
et comme l'a dit monsieur mon collègue
enfin quand les le chômage y est aussi
pour quelque chose bien évidemment mais
ça ne suffira pas quoi nous on pense à
travailler là sur le projet de loi de
finances rectificative qu'il faut aussi
agir sur les sur des nouvelles recettes
pour commenter recettes peut-être
exceptionnelles et temporaires ont ceux
qui ont quelquefois voilà qui s'en sont
bien tirés que la crise quelquefois même
profité de cette triste arrivé pour
certaines grandes entreprises etc
voilà qui est contribution qu'ils soient
exceptionnels qui permettent de
retrouver l'équipe surtout d'avoir des
réformes structurelles qui soit trop
brutale socialement ce que jacques myard
il ya une option qui est sur la table
l'option la plus simple c'est de
repousser l'âge du départ à la retraite
vous seriez pour vous savez je veux dire
une chose je vous dédie la loi d'airain
c'est le nombre de retraités par rapport
aux nombres
d'actifs si vous repousser l'âge de la
retraite bien évidemment vous reculer
les échéances
mais le point fondamental on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui un syndrome de
personnes qui proposent ou de chefs
politiques de revenir à la retraite à 60
ans sans que la retraite soit taux plein
donc c'est une escroquerie
c'est ce qu'avait proposé plus ou moins
d'ailleurs au nombre mais il est aussi
mais je reviens sur la sphère de la
natalité
c'était une hérésie je suis désolé c'est
que en modifiant le quotient familial
en tapant sur les classes moyennes on a
fait chuter bien évidemment le nombre
des naissances et donc à terme on a un
déficit
il est évident aujourd'hui qu'il faut
travailler sur tous les facteurs la
relance sera un point majeur
parle-nous tabesse des chômeurs parce
que ça c'est capital
parce que ils ne cotisent pas dans les
mêmes conditions
donc il faut travailler sur tous les
thèmes et la question de la je lirai
delà de l'âge de la retraite du recul va
résulter de l'ensemble des facteurs
si ce n'est pas si nous n'avons pas plus
de naissances
si nous n'avons pas moins de chômeurs et
bien systématiquement il n'y aura cette
loi d'airain qui va jouer et là la
retraite la réforme systémique va venir
en âge de prise de retraite ça c'est une
évidence ça s'impose tous les pays
européens l'ont fait mais il ya d'autres
facteurs au préalable sur laquelle on
peut travailler
jean guy bricout par exemple si le
gouvernement s'engage à ne pas augmenter
les impôts ni à toucher aux autres
dépenses en matière d'éducation et de
santé ce qui laisse entendre est ce que
vous seriez prêt à ce que l'âge de la
retraite soit repoussé
moi je pense qu'il faut agir sur les
comme le disait mon collègue il ya
plusieurs cures serre est l'un des
curseurs parle des recettes on parle de
dépenses on parle de la durée de
cotisation moi je suis plus pour pour
aller progressivement vers une pure est
peut-être de cotisation qui tutoie plus
longue mais qu'on tienne compte aussi
d'espérance de vie des gens je crois que
e le gouvernement a retiré complètement
les critères de pénibilité et ça c'était
l'espérance de vie pas la même pour un
ouvrier que pour pour un cadre donc je
pense qu'il faut quand même faire très
attention à ça je dirais quand même
monsieur ménard que le jeu
mon collègue que là comment dire là la
carrière longue enfin la retraite à 60
ans pour carrière longue c'était quand
même une très belle mesure de françois
hollande huit cent mille personnes sont
parties nous irait peut-être leur
expliquer que c'était une mauvaise
mesure
je pense que vous serez très malheureux
je vous signale entre amis on s'est
menti devant pour pouvoir bénéficier des
carrières longues
je pense que les gens qui ont travaillé
toutes ces années je pense qu'ils ont
bien mérité une retraite en temps
françois fillon l'a intégré dans son
projet elle avait acté notamment pour
les personnes qui avaient commencé vers
saison notamment
on est d'accord à ce propos mais de
grâce
n'oubliez pas à la politique nataliste
n'oubliez pas aussi la nécessité d'avoir
une retraite par répartition et
j'insiste pour dire que la retraite par
capitalisation revient au même c'est à
dire que c'est toujours le nombre
d'actifs par rapport au nombre de
retraités
donc il faut travailler sur tous les
facteurs et le faire je dirais en toute
transparence
et aujourd'hui le gouvernement va
reculer encore les politiques natalistes
si elle ne se fait pas sur des notions
fiscale et aux 6-10 qualité alors
attendez ça tous en même temps jacques
mignard alesi pas tous en même temps
jacques myard vous reprenez jean louis
bricout vous vous régalez vous avez
entendu on a vu que la baisse notamment
de quotient familial
la baisse du niveau des allocations
familiales sur les classes moyennes
a immédiatement entraîné une chute de la
natalité quelques années après donc faut
pas nous raconter des histoires ça a été
hélas les études notamment deux acteurs
du monde le montrent très clairement
donc vous un mot je ne suis pas d'accord
parce que je pense pas qu'on fasse des
enfants pour des questions fiscales ou
financières je rappelle que les mesures
les mesures du pressant du précédent
quinquennat c'était toucher les revenus
supérieurs à peu près 7000 euros
donc je pense que ces gens là je serai
quand même étonné qu'ils qui sait des
enfants pour des questions fiscales et
financières franchement il nous est
quelque chose que peut-être peut-être
pour conclure est-ce que vous pensez que
le gouvernement il va y aller il va
essayer de il va attaquer en son dossier
sur la réforme des retraites avant les
présidentielles
le jacques myard écoutez je crois qu'il
a compris
vous avez entendu les déclarations du
président de la république qui marche
sur des oeufs
parce que c'est exposer surtout avec la
retraite à points qui est une
escroquerie
je précise parce que là ça va donner la
main à l'administration technocratique
pour tenir l'ensemble des retraites par
la valeur du point et on l'a vu
notamment dans le système privé arrco
agirc arrco ou lille et le point n'a pas
bougé depuis maintenant six ans et que
tous les cadres ont perdu énormément
d'argent en matière de retraite
donc on a un exemple patent au la
retraite pas point est véritablement un
piège jean louis bricout pour le mot de
la fin lui sur six est récente va se
faire ou pas selon que ce soit dans le
débat des prochaines présidentielles à
ce que le gouvernement va y aller moi je
pense que ce doit être quelqu'un dans
des bas mais sur un projet qui soit
claire effectivement le système poing et
alors sa part peut-être d'une bonne
intention mais au lycée s'est plaint d'
injustice si on roule qui on reprend le
projet tel qu'il a été acté en mars a
suspendu en mars
c'est une catastrophe quoi les gens ne
savent même plus qui vont toucher
il s'est levé il sait même pas si
l'europe va augmenter pas baissé
c'était une façon c'était une
impréparation totale
cette forme de conseil d'état d'ailleurs
s'en est alerté non je pense que s'il
reprend il faudrait vraiment je pense
qu'il faut cesser de temps laissé le
temps d'instabilité
moi je pense pas qu'il osera
effectivement avec le risque social y
avoir derrière merci merci à tous les
deux d'avoir échangé en direct sur notre
antenne ce matin merci à vous jacques
myard mer les républicains maisons
laffitte et merci à vous jean louis
bricout député ps de l'aisne